how weak was the prosecution case the
prosecutor tried to link kyle
rittenhouse and his self-defense claim
with playing call of duty i kid you not
this is a thing that happened in real
life in a courtroom
did this get does this lawyer get his
degree from a cracker jack box isn't it
true when you would hang out with
dominic black you play call of duty and
other first-person shooter video games
sometimes and those are games in which
you use weapons like ar-15s to pretty
much shoot anybody who comes at you
correct it's a video game where two
players are playing together
i don't really understand the meaning of
your question to be honest isn't one of
the things people do in these video
games try and kill everyone else with
your guns
yeah it's a video game it's just a video
game it's not real life so i i love that
kyle written now has to explain to him
that video games are not real life well
done here sir well done